it's 1960 and the Nazis have taken over
the world once beautiful cities have
been transformed into oppressive urban
landscapes patrolled by Nazi troops
mechs and robotic guard dogs this is the
world of Wolfenstein the new order
a world where resistance seems futile
but there's one man who's up to the task
William BJ Blazkowicz the same Blass
kovitch who shot a lot of Nazis and took
down mecca Hitler in 1992 s Wolfenstein
3d the first few hours of the new order
take place in 1946 Blass kovitch
spearheads a last-ditch assault on the
new fortress headquarters of the Third
Reich but the operation goes awry and
blasts kovitch takes a piece of shrapnel
to the head he spends the next 14 years
as a vegetable recovering in a Polish
mental institution now this isn't just a
convenient plot device to bring the
majority of the games action into the
Nazi controlled world of 1960 the blasts
kovitch that emerges is still a blunt
instrument he's got no dark past he
doesn't suffer from any inner turmoil
he's just a man who as a side character
excitedly exclaims was born to kill
Nazis kill not as much as the new orders
plot is about blasts kovitch rebelling
against the Nazis iron grip on the
entire planet it's also about the
friction created when the original
first-person-shooter protagonist drops
into a first person shooter designed for
2014 he is a lens through which you see
how the nature of first person shooters
has changed since his first appearance
and how the world has left glass kovitch
in his intentional lack of nuance behind
he's in those eight used to be our
knives if I go anymore in combat glass
kovitch even functions like his old self
he needs health and armor pickups to
stay alive and he can carry all of his
guns at the same time this immediately
allows for a wider range of options in
any particular combat situation than a
shooter with a weapon carry limit would
offer those guns are big and loud and
really satisfying to shoot and most of
the weapons can be dual wielded which
works really well because you don't
to lose any accuracy by not aiming down
the sights this lens combat a sense of
finesse
despite its fast pace the enemy AI isn't
all that complex but it still works in
the context of this kind of shooter
instead larger enemies like Nazi robots
add variety to combat through their
increased threat and the fact that
different tactics are required to take
them down and all the while the combat
feedback is dialed to eleven levels flow
back and forth really nicely through
tight corridors and wide open arenas
though enemy numbers in those levels
never reach the access of say do more
Serious Sam like hordes there isn't a
variety in the combat spaces and the
enemy combinations within that the new
orders levels feel well paced and combat
feels tense without being unmanageable
or overwhelming some rudimentary yet
functional stealth mechanics allow the
new order to craft entire levels where
blasts kovitch is armed with nothing but
a knife these quiet tense sections add
variety to the game's pacing the
presence of nazi commanders who can call
in reinforcements if they detect you
create a hierarchy of high-value targets
in a single room it's rewarding to feel
like you're stealthily stalking them
taking them out silently and then you're
free to pull out the big guns and clear
an area in the most efficient manner
possible with these mechanics along with
some interesting mission locations and
stellar environmental design the new
order offers a wide variety of combat
experiences blasts kovitch can unlock
both stealth and combat perks but the
tasks required to do so like stealth
killing a certain number of Nazis are
mostly actions that you perform
naturally over time the perks themselves
provide only subtle effects like
slightly extra ammo so you'd be forgiven
for forgetting that their system exists
at all
weapon upgrades which are found
throughout the game's levels offer more
tangible benefits like additional
tactical avenues assault rifles can be
upgraded to fire underslung rockets and
shotguns can be made to fire shells that
bounce off walls effectively turning
them into
real tournaments flak cannon you also
need to make use of a laser cutter but
it's mostly relegated to cutting Blas
kovitch sized holes in the only pieces
of metal grating that are blocking your
forward progress in the first place both
this laser cutter and the perk system
feel like missed opportunities at worst
even aside from them the new orders
combat intensity and variety has granted
the Wolfenstein series a breath of fresh
air whilst still managing to hit the
nostalgic highs that I expect from the
series the game has even injected some
substance into the primal pleasure of
shooting Nazis by way of an interesting
tone that addresses the changing roles
of first-person shooter protagonists
just kidding
through this the game is both a
celebration of and what feels like a
fitting send-off for the Wolfenstein
series as a whole the new order could be
the last row of William BJ Blazkowicz an
outing which for all its success and
bombast
is far from mindless
Oh
okay